[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes
el impacto de la violencia en género una
intervención del estado para restablecer
el orden público y garantizar que los
colombianos tengan unos derechos y unas
libertades bajo este contexto muchos
historiadores coinciden con que el
problema del conflicto se generó por las
tierras por la falta de la legalidad de
estos predios no sé si ustedes recuerdan
pero en 1948 se generó uno de los actos
más violentos que hemos tenido con el
bogotazo aquí surgen los grupos armados
para la época entre los 80 y la década
de los 90 se presentaron también los
actos más atroces y terroristas que se
han presentado en nuestro país
estos actos de violencia
no solo se quedaron allí sino que
generaron muchas víctimas en el
conflicto armado interno son más de 8
millones de víctimas que tenemos en
nuestro país pero de esas 8 millones de
víctimas 54 mil 464 son policías y sus
familias
tal vez ustedes recuerdan con esta
imagen como en el servicio de policía
rural
esta imagen nos transporta a esos
escenarios donde el estado tuvo que
especializar a su fuerza pública
para combatir a estos grupos armados
ilegales
es colombia nuestro territorio según
cifras del agua 5 así el 99.6 por ciento
de colombia es verde y en este color
verde hay unos territorios alejados y
unas veredas que nosotros en estos
momentos no podríamos describir su
belleza
y ustedes que están aquí sentados si
quisieran ir alguna vez una experiencia
que tuvimos tendrían que un avión
llegar a la ciudad principal por ejemplo
en el caso nuestro subir a un
helicóptero llegar a lo alto de la
montaña y poder aterrizar en un sector
donde caminamos en alguna ocasión 40
minutos hasta llegar a un río en ese río
tomamos un bote el bote nos condujo
hasta la escuela que íbamos a tener un
encuentro comunitario
luego de atravesar el río estuvimos
aproximadamente 15 minutos y en esa
escuela encontramos un salón un salón
que lo compartían niños en edades entre
los 5 y los 16 años pero esto no causó
tanto impacto por la felicidad de los
niños pero cuando estábamos en el
encuentro y ellos nos narraban que una
de sus necesidades era que le
construyeran una letrina a la escuela
nosotros quedamos algo asombrados porque
dijimos radioshack y ni siquiera piden
un baño
esas son de algunas algunas de las
realidades que vivimos en el sector
rural
sin embargo la policía desplegó 1200
hombres que se capacitarán no para
enfrentar a los grupos armados ilegales
sino para construir tejido social que
reto tan importante el servicio de
policía se trasladó a los lugares más
más lejanos de colombia y en estas
veredas estos policías carabineros
llegaron para prestar un servicio de
policía diferenciado focalizado y
articulado
pero cuando llegamos allá teníamos otra
misión importante como lo íbamos a hacer
y aquí juega un rol importante romper el
hielo como rompimos el hielo a través de
una mano a través de estrechar un abrazo
a través de la invitación de un café en
una zona donde había desconfianza y no
sabíamos si aceptar o no ese café
entendimos que conocer las realidades
también implicaba utilizar otras
metodologías
y esas metodologías las realizamos a
través del juego con actividades lúdicas
recreativas y deportivas pero ustedes
dirán como los policías a través del
juego pues a través del juego enlazamos
lazos de confianza que nos permitieron
entender las diferencias entender esas
diferencias porque en una colombia
diversa donde hay diferentes culturas
donde hay diferentes lenguas nosotros
nos apropiamos eso como nuestro ese
territorio a esos territorios lejanos
llegaron policías
que dejaron atrás sus familias que
dejaron atrás sus lugares
para llegar a complementarse con esta
comunidad
en el marco de esas diferencias también
utilizamos actividades recreativas y en
esas actividades también como las
deportivas por ejemplo en los juegos
donde son colectivos como el fútbol como
el baloncesto como el voleibol ustedes
se han dado cuenta que siempre hay un
árbitro que es el que rige las reglas
pero en el campo todos somos iguales
en esos ejercicios
aprendimos
a comprender las situaciones esas
situaciones que nos generaron a nosotros
transformar los conflictos de una manera
diferente de mediar los de una manera
diferente pero también generaron la
construcción de unos nuevos roles esos
roles que están teniendo en estos
momentos hay a nuestros policías van
desde ser educadores para llegar a la
escuela más lejana también prestan
algunos servicios médicos como atención
primaria ante una emergencia
y desarrollan múltiples actividades como
por ejemplo esta biblioteca móvil que es
un caso donde un niño de 5 años se le
acerca a nuestra policía en una de sus
actividades diarias y le dice tú me
podrías ayudar a hacer la tarea la
verdad es que mi mamá no la entiende un
niño de 5 años y nace una iniciativa de
recrear estas bibliotecas con
actividades lúdicas con vídeos que
permitan asesorar a los niños en el
campo con sus tareas
luego de conocer estas realidades
generamos lazos de confianza donde todos
sumamos voces y acciones para la
convivencia
en este encuentro que tenemos con la
comunidad logramos identificar quién en
el territorio no son solo los problemas
que también hay actitudes positivas que
hay cosas muy positivas que se están
generando esas actividades positivas
nosotros las hemos impulsado y las hemos
acompañado y se han generado procesos
diferentes donde también hemos utilizado
el juego
estas realidades del territorio nos
llevan a que algunos de esos
acompañamientos se generen por ejemplo
con la sustitución de las hojas de coca
la sustitución de las hojas de coca para
generar unos proyectos productivos estos
proyectos productivos han generado
también desarrollo en el país
como por ejemplo en esta fotografía
ustedes observan uno de los proyectos
que hacen referencia a uno de los cafés
que se están produciendo en el
territorio todo esto nos ha permitido a
nosotros entender que a pesar de las
adversidades que a pesar de las
dificultades haciendo empatía con las
comunidades y con las instituciones se
pueden llegar a algunos acuerdos
teniendo en cuenta las diferencias de
cada uno para generar una transformación
de conflictos que no sean violentos
para un mejor país pero esto no termina
aquí realmente este es el comienzo de un
nuevo ciclo donde conectamos las ideas
realmente para transformar las
realidades muchas gracias
[Aplausos]